[Musique]
la présidente chen feng fait campagne
dans l'ouest catholique de belfast ici
beaucoup espèrent que cette élection
sera un tournant dans l'histoire le
cuisant siècle l'irlande du nord est
dominé par des élus fidèles à la
couronne britannique
[Musique]
in fine à la possibilité de devenir le
plus grand parti mais aussi de remporter
le siège de premier ministre
cela veut dire qu'en termes d'histoire
contemporaine la politique a changé en
irlande la société est plus ouverte et
plus progressistes mais aussi nous
avançons sur la route de la
réunification la fin de la partition un
siècle après
on avance vers l'unification de
l'irlande
après 35 ans de conflit les termes de
l'accord de paix signé en 1998 ont été
accepté par l'immense majorité des
nord-irlandais attire landais être
britannique des questions d'identité
notre passionné plus les jeunes
électeurs jusqu'à ce que le bras exit
relance le débat
je suis à 100% pour une irlande unie
si on veut rejoindre l'europe si on veut
voyager voyons les choses ainsi si on
veut faire partie de l'europe c'est
notre moyen d'y arriver
en rejoignant la république d'irlande
l'irlande du nord deviendrait à nouveau
membre à part entière de l'union
européenne pour de nombreuses unionistes
une telle idée c'est jouer avec le feu
pendant la campagne et rassemblements
ont été organisés pour afficher
l'opposition aux femmes protocole de
l'accord britannique sortie de l'ue ce
protocole a créé une frontières
commerciales entre la grande bretagne et
l'irlande du nord le chef du principal
parti unioniste le dmp est un grand
supporter du brésil
nous ne pouvons pas avancer avant que
les unionistes ne l'acceptent et ça veut
dire pas de protocole nous n'acceptons
pas le protocole
tant que le protocole demeure que des
oeufs peuvent bloquer la restauration de
l'assemblée d'irlande une a suspendu en
début d'année
le protocole à diluer notre relation
avec le reste du royaume uni ils
endommagent la stabilité politique en
irlande du nord abîme notre économie
augmente le coût de la vie parce que
faire venir les produits de grande
bretagne coûte beaucoup plus cher
nous devons donc remplacer le protocole
par des arrangements qui respecte la
place de l'irlande au sein du royaume
uni
avec fifres et tambours le chef coûté
huppé martèlent les viols slogan
identitaire espérant rallier les
électeurs unionistes sous l'union jack
un autre rassemblement sous les couleurs
du même drapeau ici à chaque film une
commerçante se plaint de l'impact du
protocole sur ces affaires
fini le protocole tant pis pour les
conséquences
baisse l'oni dirige cette pépinière
depuis plus de trente ans puis que le
royaume uni a quitté lui et ses
fournisseurs jambes mais refuse de
livrer en irlande du nord à cause des
frais d'exportations vers une région
rester dans le marché unique
ces plantes alpines on les achetait
habituellement en angleterre mais plus
depuis que le protocole est appliquée
j'ai envoyé un courriel pour essayer de
me faire livrer ils ont dit non
et désormais forcés d'acheter ces roses
à un intermédiaire en république
d'irlande
[Musique]
eux
ils les reçoivent du même fournisseur il
change les pots et nous les revendre en
irlande du nord
fait aussi du protocole une question
d'identité en tant que citoyenne
britannique je me sens coupé de mon
propre pays
dont l'ouest catholique de belfast
l'analyse du problème est différente
les problèmes qui frappent la chaîne
d'approvisionnement sont créés par le
brr exit pas par le protocole le
protocole est la réponse au moins en
partie aux difficultés du brick city
sur la côte nord dont prime ce grossiste
importe des denrées alimentaires de
grande bretagne pour les vendre à
travers l'île d'irlande il a donc été
frappé de plein fouet par le bras exit
en revanche pour cet entrepreneur le
plus frustrant est de voir qu'à chaque
élection ici les questions commerciales
deviennent un enjeu identitaire de ce
pays que le protocole pourrait avoir des
bénéfices à long terme si une solution
raisonnable été trouvé pour le contrôle
des marchandises
comment prendre en compte le fait que
l'irlande soit une île
comment commercer plus facilement ici
comme avec la grande bretagne
voici les problèmes concrets dont nous
devrions parler plutôt que de retourner
à la même vieille rengaine à chaque
campagne
après le vote les citoyens s'attendent
normalement à ce que leurs élus forme un
gouvernement mais ici rien n'est moins
sûr l'avenir de l'assemblée d'irlande du
nord est une nouvelle fois remise en
question